we're willing to bet that your wearable
doesn't come with the power of the force
spiros bb-8 droid was last year's
must-have toy and this year they're
launching a new model with a new look
and new powers instead of using the
antenna in your phone where it competes
with Wi-Fi or LTE signals this wristband
is dedicated to the Droid only and uses
motion controls for extra precision that
means you can control bb-8 from much
farther away it's a little less forced
push and a little more flick of the
wrist but once you get bb-8 moving it's
a hell of a lot of fun play a game of
bb-8 machi and see who can get him
closest to the wall without touching or
have him chase you around like he does
with Poe Finn or Rey in the force
awakens instead of a slick glossy finish
this version of bb-8 is as close to
movie perfect as possible
check out the matte finish and the
battle damage from his adventures with
poe dameron's when you're not driving
mediate the force band also has force
awareness mode a more passive collecting
game that falls somewhere between the
top Star Wars trading card app and
Pokemon go it allows users to collect
characters and vehicles from the Star
Wars universe ranging from common to
legendary and it'll definitely scratch
that collector rich you'll get so used
to wearing your Force Band that you
might even forget bb-8 is following you
around
hey buddy